[Music]
the movie your character is very funny
and but and you're very convincing
acting this person who is sort of coked
up drunk a lot yeah pretty much out of
it yes unsub say I I found that very
hard because you know when the director
wit met with me and the boys project she
said you've done coke right and I said
uh yeah that's how every job interview
in Hollywood goes
sex hurts and I obviously have never
even seen coke but I had to win it so I
started asking my friends I said you
know I'm researching for this role you
know what's it like to be on coke and
they would think what I was always on
coke it turns out they thought we you
know we thought you were high as a kite
most of the time because I guess my
natural personality is quite I can
relate to this because I have had this
is true story but I've had people that
only know me from the television show
who I went and saw a doctor once and
he's just asking me these different
questions and he's like I'm what kind of
drugs of use and I'm a real
I'm very square I don't do anything I
never did anything and then he said the
cocaine I said no I never did he said
come on I've seen you on TV yeah no
that's desperate self-hate
and when you look back I remember I used
to go to parties and people always
coming up to me saying if you got any
blow and that's why right they thought
it
oh she's acting all kind of hyper and
loud and yeah so what do you do as an
actor you need to simulate an experience
that you have never had what do you do
well we were pretty drunk throughout
this whole movie and at Kirsten dance
once one of the actors on this movie she
she taught us this trick to act drunk
which is where you stand on the spot and
then you just basically spin in a circle
but you keep your head down and and we
would just do that again and again while
they said rolling and speed and then
when they said action we were kind of
off-balance and were able to do that
impediment yeah I've never heard of that
acting technique before you spin around
yeah crazy and then the cameras roll and
you're just yeah yeah if you want to be
even more specific you could put ice in
your mouth so that your tongues numbs
they sound really janta okay my acting
is better in the movie I promise or you
could just drink a lot before every
scene well okay we have a clip here from
the Bachelorette from Bachelorette
anything we need to know for this scene
um I believe we're Mike my character
Katie who's not blessed with brains is
talking about how she feels about her
life I think you think you're not sure I
didn't run the clip I barely made it out
here I couldn't get through the game so
you have no idea what that clip is no I
think if you've been spinning around
before this interview haven't you
you're a backstage go on
gotta go on that works cute they would
be really proud of you for doing that by
the way okay let's take it where are we
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
knows what it's like to be on coke scrip
from Bachelorette do you believe in
magic yes I do
that's absolutely believing a magic
vagina
it would be which you with its magic I
did bewitched by vagina before it's very
actually I think I might be stupid why
would you say that about yourself I
don't understand anything anyone is
talking about most of the time that has
nothing to do with intelligence it's
like this there's lots of different
kinds of smart you know and you just
have to discover which smart you are
see I I don't understand what you just
said that's okay the new life be honest
would you marry a stripper
[Applause]